a wisecrack jared here and today we're
talking about a game that was seemingly
made for us perhaps the most overtly
philosophical game ever
Neera tomahto Nier automata is a game
about three androids to be as in or not
to be
the Moody 9s and the jaded a2 along the
way they fight adorable but lethal
machines and eventually each other on a
futuristic earth where the line between
right and wrong has taken a vacation and
is never coming back the world of near
automata is crawling with machines named
after philosophers who you must befriend
or behead mostly the latter but these
wisdom loving deathbots aren't always
just throwaway characters they often
point toward the complex philosophy at
the heart of the game at its core Nier
automata challenges players to consider
how we make meaning in truth who we are
as gamers and why video games matter
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of near automata this video
was made in collaboration with an
awesome channel called extra credits you
can catch a link to them and their video
on near automata
at the end of this episode and if you're
visiting us from extra credits welcome
and be sure to subscribe
oh and watch out major spoilers ahead
the story takes place on earth more than
nine thousand years in the future and
follows two groups of automata there's
androids designed to hold human
consciousness but who eventually develop
independent thought and machines who
were created by the aliens that invaded
earth androids and machines fight a
genocide approxi war on behalf of their
masters though the player mostly
controls Android characters choosing
sides is not that easy because by the
game's halfway point we learned both
humans and aliens have been dead for
millennia humans were already extinct
when the aliens attacked absent their
creators androids and machines are
forced to make meaning for themselves
and if possible stop seeing each other
as enemies the fact that both humans and
aliens are dead is not only a central
plot twist it encapsulates the game's
existential philosophy in fact two bees
opening line I often think about the God
who blessed
this cryptic puzzle and wonder if we'll
ever have the chance to kill him might
as well have been pulled right from
friedrich pornstache nietzsche who wrote
god is dead god remains dead and we have
killed him now I know the phrase god is
dead gets thrown around a lot by
internet edge lords but what did
Nietzsche actually mean before Nietzsche
many thinkers constructed reality in a
similar way God truth and reason were
all unfappable unchanging and universal
concepts which stood above or outside of
humankind like supernatural forces
animating the world and moving it toward
progress in this view humans don't make
and control meaning themselves it's some
unreachable deity or universal principle
which gives human action meaning one
need to declare God dead he criticized
any system that locates the source of
meaning outside human lives and
popularized the idea of nihilism
nihilism is the belief that there is no
great metaphysical force propelling us
through the world and making our lives
special existence can be steep and
there's no grander meaning to comfort us
no puppet master to save us now I know
we can find Nietzsche in a lot of pop
culture but no piece of media embodies
it quite like Nier automata androids and
machines think they're godlike masters
are literally above them on the moon and
in space but those gods are actually
dead like rotting for millenia dead and
as we learn from Adam and Eve machines
killed their alien overlords because
they were static and unchanging much
like the unchanging deities and morals
that Nietzsche criticized
they were humans died after the
mainframe holding their consciousnesses
collapses guess nobody made backups if
the death of God is really about the
death of a grand meaning then our dead
aliens and humans are only one element
of the game's greater message about
meaning you kill some of philosophies
biggest heroes some characters lose
sight of a purpose in life and the game
repeatedly builds meaning around certain
characters or plots and then kills them
off usually by the players own hand each
time this happens the player has to
reevaluate where their new meaning
mission and direction is going to come
from even your HUD the Android
organization eventually dies but your
highs less like a god and more like a
seedy government they know humanity's
dead but hide it from the other Androids
pretty [ __ ] up right your ha perfectly
exemplifies the Nietzschean point that
even once God's Six Feet Under
society doesn't just reboot political
social and psychological norms are left
over from prior belief systems and we
continue imposing these meanings on one
another and ourselves to be and 9's
spend much of the a and B playthroughs
reassuring one another that machines
don't have emotions or personhood that
don't have any feelings they're just
imitating human speech even when all
evidence points to the contrary no need
for human masters to promote this idea
they do it to each other
burn each of the best response to a
meaningless universe and a dead God is
to create meaning for ourselves or what
he referred to as self making in near
atomic ah we encounter different
machines named after philosophers
engaged in this kind of self making each
with their own responses to the meaning
or meaninglessness of life there are
quite a few existentialist machines to
be found
jean-paul as in Sartre Simone as in de
Beauvoir Pascal as in Pascal and
Kierkegaard as in Kierkegaard each
philosopher machine offers us a glimpse
into one way of pursuing meaning take
John Paul the avatar of jean-paul Sartre
in the game JP is basically a dark
parody of his real-life self just like
Sartre loathed institutional recognition
jean-paul is kind of an [ __ ] who
ignores his devoted follower
except for the pretty ones and
eventually freaks off to the wilderness
to find meaning nobody really misses him
but before leaving jean-paul highlights
the game's themes when he throws around
one or two famous Sartre isms like the
existential slogan existence precedes
essence essentially rather than some
innate nature determining who we are
before we're born each individual first
exists in the world and then develops
meaning and purpose it's all about
radical freedom to become who we are
through our actions and choices in the
game we see this everywhere as machines
transcend their intended purpose and
find new meaning even the pods prove
that their nature comes from existence
not a predetermined essence as they
develop self-consciousness in fact most
of the characters in the game are as
Sartre once suggested condemned to be
free that's right condemned because
without a higher power or innate nature
controlling our actions we bear ultimate
responsibility for our decisions even as
morality becomes super ambiguous and
that's a tough place to be just look at
machines like this sad angles boss who
like many of the game's characters is
crushed beneath the weight of figuring
out what's right and he knows he bears
full responsibility for those decisions
the Simone boss named after Simone de
Beauvoir a French feminist philosopher
holds a mirror to another aspect of
meaning-making
de Beauvoir famously suggested one is
not born a woman but becomes a woman as
the Simone boss realizes one way we
create meaning in our lives is by
constructing gender norms like beauty
and femininity she literally becomes a
woman by constructing herself and
cannibalizing other machines to improve
her beauty both de Beauvoir and her
demented avatar teach us to watch out
lest we become monsters in our attempt
to make meaning through gender norms
Simone's
existential quest for connection through
Beauty is highlighted in her obsession
with jean-paul which has historical
roots since de Beauvoir
and Sartre were lifelong lovers the
character Pascal packs one of the
biggest Nietzschean punches though he's
the avatar of Blaise Pascal a
mathematician philosopher and regular
Renaissance man he couldn't be more
different than his real-life counterpart
as the pacifist leader of a machine
village
Pascal puts a lot of faith in the
ultimate goodness of machines and
Androids but the real Pascal was a bit
of a downer unlike his idealistic avatar
the real Pascal thought humanity was
prideful arrogant and unredeemable
without God our lives are filled with
anxiety and despair in fact we have only
one redeeming trait the greatness of
human beings consists in their ability
to know their wretchedness but game
Pascal comes around to the IRL Pascal's
viewpoint and maybe the game's darkest
twist the peaceful villagers suddenly
start eating each other and when even
after setting aside his pacifism to
defend the children they commit suicide
anyway game Pascal finally understands
the wretchedness of himself and the
machine when he despairs and asks you to
kill him or delete his memory the player
has to face their own wretchedness too
and make a tough choice some characters
in the near universe try to make meaning
through new religions take Christian
existentialist Soren Kierkegaard who
makes an ironic appearance as the
worship leader of a small cult
Kierkegaard believed that the ultimate
expression of one's freedom is to commit
to certain meaning and make it true by
manifesting it in one's life which he
calls taking a leap of faith
unfortunately when some of Kierkegaard's
followers take literal leaps of faith it
doesn't turn out so well for them there
are so many other philosophies we could
talk about call Grune Conte angles and
marks Ernst Bloch Hegel even the
brothers Friedrich and Auguste Slagle
Roshi Koshi Boko she and Sochi are the
Japanese pronunciations of Chinese
philosophers Lao Xu Confucius matzah and
Gwang soo Kwang soo was a Taoist
philosopher who was in the
existentialism way before it was cool he
claimed existence is full of cycles of
light and dark life and death and joy
and sadness only by accepting these
cycles including all the unpleasant
stuff can we ever find contentment in
life near automata
taking a cue from Duong to makes these
cycles right into the gameplay as an
extension of the game's existential
themes the mechanics emphasize the role
of cycles and repetition in creating
meaning cycles are everywhere androids
are caught in the cycle of life and
death
repeatedly uploading to the mainframe
and getting new body
to be is stuck in the cycle of killing
9s and pod 153 gives a sad spiel about
cycles of life it's all about returning
to the beginning according to Nietzsche
cycles dispel the myth of progress
progress only makes sense if you have a
clear aim and if your coolest thing on a
path that someone else laid out for you
but Nietzsche hates that notion of
progress instead we should be critical
of claims to progress that rely on
external meaning or our unquestioned
notions of right and wrong the cycles an
automaton disrupt this false idea of
progress and meaning not only within the
game universe but also for the player in
automata there is no clear goal or
rather goals change throughout the game
and the whole point is that none of the
characters are on a predetermined path
plus there's no straightforward game
progress players literally repeat
certain actions or stories rather than
moving linearly from one event to the
next the game even ends with the
suggestion that pay 2 & 9s will be
reborn to fight this battle all over
again
in fact relationship between cycles and
nature are most obvious in the games
multiple playthrough structure in
automata the main playthroughs a B C D
and E are like chapters carefully
sequenced and building on one another
often repeating parts of the same plot
but through the eyes knowledge and
powers of different characters and
sometimes moving on to the next plot
stage you must complete a through D to
get to the main ending e with the
credits which we'll talk about in a
moment
automata uses this structure to strip
meaning from the players themselves and
to put the idea of game progress
engaging players in their own nihilist
quest instead of the difference between
the first and second playthroughs where
you play as to be and then 9s in
parallel stories in the first play as to
be you learn the aliens are dead and the
machines we've been killing are actually
sentient and emotional of course they
could have just told us this straight
out but instead they make us relive
everything we did to those poor bastards
and now we feel terrible about it the
real importance of the first run is to
set up meaning here's who you are and
why you're fighting the bad guys and
then snap
from us the point is really driven home
by the beginning of the second
playthrough where you play from the
perspective of a machine redshirt this
opening seems designed to trigger the
players compassion and robbed us of the
meaning we use to make sense of our
entire first quest instead of creating a
grand narrative to explain away pain and
loss or instead of just giving up me
just suggest we say yes to life yes
saying is an attitude oriented toward
the future that affirms everything from
the past without trying to change it
imagine you had to live the same life
over and over in what Nietzsche calls
eternal recurrence this would be super
crappy if you thought life was about
avoiding pain and suffering but yes
Tseng embraces suffering and the lessons
it brings us without glorifying them the
game's final Nietzsche and middle finger
to progress and ultimate meaning comes
in ending II here players literally have
to kill their gods and make a difficult
choice between progress which lets them
save all their data and advancement in
the game and yes saying which entails
accepting their mistakes and be willing
to start over as the credits roll and
you battle the names of the game's
designers and creators which are somehow
shooting at you messages from other
players around the world encourage you
until you're finally joined by their
avatars who sacrifice themselves for
your success and I don't use sacrifice
lightly as you discover at the end when
you're asked to do the same all those
avatars are there because in some other
time in place maybe before you even
started playing other players finish the
game and chose to delete their data and
game saves for the ability to eventually
help you a total stranger complete the
game here we're asked what makes gaming
meaningful do we believe in the myth of
progress that what makes them meaningful
is completing them saving our data and
having achieved something once and for
all or are we yes sayers willing to
start over from the beginning and make
the same choices and maybe even the same
mistakes all over again
are we individual otama tah who only
fight for ourselves or is gaming about
the lessons we learn and engaging a
community does one player deserve the
sacrifice made by others and should we
sacrifice ourselves for people who we
don't know or might not even like what
makes gaming meaningful is
surely up to the player if you affirm
progress nothing happened but if you say
yes to suffering and loss instead all
your saves and play get deleted and you
return to the beginning to do it all
again or maybe you'll do it differently
a future is not given to you this is
something you must take for yourself see
cycles as a game near otama saw itself
embraces suffering both of its
characters and its players but only in
order to tell a powerful philosophical
story as only an interactive game could
does it pan out like they hoped is the
game worth all the fields that elicits
in an attempt to make its point about
meaning well that's up to you but if
you're one of the yes heirs who
sacrifice me my journey possible you
should though it means something to me
and part of the reason it means
something to me is because this ending
is a rare example of game developers
baking empathy into the gameplay while
video games are on the surface all about
saving the world and helping people most
of them lack core components of what
makes axe truly empathetic to learn more
about how Nier automata breaks the mold
you'll have to check out our
collaborators over at extra credits who
are broken down the ending in a whole
new light be sure to tell them that
wisecrack sent you as always be sure to
subscribe and ring that Bell catch y'all
next time
peace